[Musique]
ici rue des morillons à paris les objets
perdus se transforme en objets trouvés
d'anonymes ces objets inanimés retrouve
à l'efo dame une identité ils sont
fichés numérotée répertorier classer et
puis chacun file vers sa destinée
ayrault au regard des
pièces 10 à 20 francs et 15 à 10 francs
c'est la grande trouvaille de la matinée
ça monsieur au moment des louis d'or une
bague
bracelet
et des gourmettes y en a pour de
l'argent là ça a été perdu quand ben
c'était perdu vendredi sur la numéro 8
et ont apporté ce matin ici avec tous
les objets trouvés par la ratp dans
cette journée
et ses objets précieux le sud est et
dans quoi dans un mauvais ça y est vous
dans ce port document monsieur qui tous
les chiffres et 12 ha c'est étonnant
car il
accepta pointures
monsieur cunéo chef du service des
séquestres veut bien aujourd'hui nous
faire connaître le secret de quelques
objets trouvés on trouve vraiment touché
cieux cunéo de la poupée gonflable au
louis d'or absolument tu vois la
personne n'est qui a perdu ses leaders
si elle nous regarde en ce moment et
qu'elle voit ce spectacle elle va être
très impressionné par ce qu'on va penser
qu'elle sera en même temps soulagée
puisqu'elle sera qui sont arrivés à bon
port s'il arrive sinon qu'on perde des
objets de grande valeur chez un ami oui
ça arrive assez fréquemment
les objets qu'ils atteignent oui
plusieurs dizaines de millions anciens
du background et bandé astree d'écoliers
des bijoux enfin de grande valeur et
tous les objets que nous venons de voir
sur cette grave lacune voyant aubrac
tony proviennent de la ratp ses dires de
métro et les autobus c'est ça c'est un
des canaux par lesquels nous parviennent
les objets trouvés vous avez la ratp qui
fait tout le réseau paris et les trois
départements de la petite couronne vous
avez tous les commissariats de paris et
de banlieue et les taxis combien
d'objets pertes on balance environ
actuellement lieu nous avons à peu près
180 mille objets et combien sont
retrouvés ici alors que retrouver ici ça
des restitués c'est très décevant parce
qu'il n'y a pas un tiers qui reste cause
ce fait c'est ce que les français n'y
croit pas on ne l'est pas il faut croire
ils ont bientôt
combien d'employés vous ici ou ici pour
les objets trouvés g
à peu près 55 employés
monsieur vécu et où nous sommes ici
devant le seul secteur vraiment libre
des objets trouvés staff que là on
rentre pour voir si on retrouve son
trousseau de clés cet exode oui parce
que ceux qui perdent des prix bien sûr
en général n'ont pas l'adresse avec ses
clés ils sont bien obligés de venir
eux-mêmes bois recherché par ces
connaisseurs il n'y a pas de danger que
quelqu'un prenne les clés d'un autre
pour aller y fracturer sa peur à foix
travers moi car ça partait prendre les
objets qu'ils possèdent il faut savoir
avec cette clé correspond à 14
quelconque et pas l'adresse est quand
même difficile à l'adresse sur les
étiquettes est-ce que très souvent on
essaye de vous deux du ps que des gens
qui veulent se procurer un parapluie par
exemple viennent ici en vous disant
qu'ils ont perdu a rappelé pas très
souvent mais ça arrive qu'est ce que
vous faites alors écoutez on ne demande
tellement de détails sur le lieu de la
perte la date
comment il fait le parapluie enfin
toutes sortes de détails que lille est
quand même difficile de nous occuper une
des marques phares avec jamais mais
enfin c'est certainement très rare en
tout cas nous en sommes pas aperçu
monsieur meunier c'est la sonnerie que
vous avez l'habitude d'entendre puisque
vous êtes le responsable de ce vaste
magasin le chef magasinier en quelque
sorte de cet entrepôt il vous devez
avoir connu beaucoup d'échantillons de
l'humanité à travers tous ces objets
peut-être connaissez-vous une belle
histoire les histoires que j'ai connu la
plus belle histoire j'ai pu connaître
ici c'est un geste la part d'un boucher
qui allait faire seront achard aux
halles est à court de l'autre et il a
perdu sa serviette à quelques dizaines
de millions de da et c'est un honnête
éboueurs qui a trouvé cette serviette en
avant son travail et quand il s'est
aperçu la totalité d'argent qui avait
john et a fait demi tour au chili puis
paniquer comme parrain et c'est pourquoi
pas faire et ils attendent ils fassent
jour aux portes et l'assemblage a comme
ça de police et cette somme d'argent a
été transmis à biétry chez nous et le
propriétaire alors que le boucher du
récupéo somme d'argent avec le labeur et
boucher a fait cadeau cette somme
d'argent
les verts il a fait un bel arbre de noël
aux enfants parce que ce thème la
famille nombreuse et en plus de ça le
boucher a approché de ses enfants comme
commis
bien ici monsieur tuner où nous sommes
dans le dans le ventre de votre domaine
nous sommes dans le magasin où l'on
entrepose tous les objets et cela durant
trois quatre mois c'est à dire que tout
ce que nous voyons ici et d'entreposer
depuis trois mois environ au moins alors
là les objets les plus les plus
hétéroclites ya des postes de télévision
des transistors des statuts des casques
de moto des chandails des culottes des
chaussettes que sais-je enfin irm une
statue c'est assez étonnant comment
peut-on perdre des objets pareil on va
écouter nous avons des objets de valeur
nous en avons pas compte qu'ils ont
beaucoup moins de valeur comment
peuvent-ils être perdu ça je pense tout
simplement que les gens perdent un peu
la tête les gens sont honnêtes il se
dérangent pour apporter des objets qui à
première vue n'ont aucune valeur mais se
dérangent tout de même pensant peut-être
je suppose que les gens sont heureux de
retrouver dans le cas où vous vous
trouvez par exemple le portefeuille des
papiers ses papiers ne sont pas rendus
ni réclamer que deviennent les cartes
d'identité les papiers etc écoutez dès
que nous avons des objets avec des
adresses nous écrivons tout de suite aux
intéressés s'ils ne réclament pas ces
objets race ont détruit bien dans le
domaine de la suite à part une très
belle collection d'appareils de photos
voici une jambe artificielle
je me demande comment on peut oublier
une jambe artificielle sage nous avons
c'est un mystère parce que nous n'avons
jamais pu le savoir nous en avons ce à
différentes reprises et les jambes de
bois même l'arrêt tilloy des piles enfin
ce qu'on appelle des plans des gens d
articuler mais on n'a jamais su bien sûr
comment il avait été perdue puisque
personne n'est venu et réclamer ça vous
arrive selon madame de perdre quelque
chose c'est la première fois que vous
venez aux objets trouvés ici oui est-ce
que vous avez déjà trouvé quelque chose
alors à ça m'est arrivé
à certains petits chiens trouvés c'est
un petit chien est adopté
c'est vrai combien de temps que vous
l'avez 7 8 mois
madame je vous souhaite de retrouver
votre sac le plus rapidement possible
merci à madame
bien voyez-vous cette dame qui a
rapporté un objet qu'elle avait perdue
est parti en oubliant son papy c'est le
comble de l'étourderie ça arrive souvent
ça arrive assez souvent oui à telle
enseigne qu'on a pensé
mettre sur pied un service des objets
perdus aux objets trouvés
[Musique]